chaque année le sénat offre à ses élus
40 aller retour en avion et une carte
illimitée sur le réseau sncf en première
classe
[Musique]
reste à découvrir son bureau
un petit peu moins les gens rien qu'en
faisant le fonctionnaire y'a pas un
espace démesurément avant ils mesurent
une quinzaine de mètres carrés et
devrait ainsi voir sinon je suis pas la
table en plus de ses nouvelles fonctions
le train de vie du jeune sénateur va
considérablement changer
il va toucher une indemnité de 5500
euros nets mensuels plus une enveloppe
de 6000 euros par mois pour ses frais
sans justificatifs et non imposable
à cela s'ajoute 7500 euros par mois pour
payer des assistants mais aussi dix
mille euros tous les six ans pour
l'informatique
un forfait de téléphone les nuits
d'hôtel à paris les jours de séances en
tous sens les charges
chaque sénateur coûte en moyenne aux
contribuables 23 1500 euros par mois
mais les sénateurs ne sont pas les plus
gros salaires de l'institution le palais
du luxembourg abrite plus de mille deux
cents fonctionnaires recrutés sur
concours
ils sont parmi les meilleurs de france
dans leur domaine et aussi les mieux
payés du pays pour 32 heures par semaine
un jardinier ou un agent d'entretien
comment sa carrière à 2500 euros net par
mois
les chauffeurs secrétaires ou dactylo
gagne environ 5000 euros par mois les
huissiers commencent eux aussi à 5000
euros
comme les administrateurs qui eux
finissent leur carrière à plus de 10000
euros
la palme revient au secrétaire général
ici à gauche de l'écran à 20000 euros
mensuels c'est le plus haut
fonctionnaire du sénat est un des mieux
payés de france
[Musique]
c'est lui jean-louis rhin il a été nommé
par les sénateurs il y a deux ans il a
refusé nos demandes d'interview
nous n'aurons pas le droit non plus
d'interroger les fonctionnaires de la
maison
[Musique]